hey this is presh tallwalker
a b c d is a rectangle with a b equal to
four and b c equal to eight
construct the arc a e centered at b
where point e is along the side bc then
construct the arc cf centered at e where
f is along the side a d
the question is what is the area of the
region a f c e
shaded in blue
i think anu verb for the suggestion
pause the video if you'd like to give
this problem a try
and when you're ready keep watching to
learn how to solve this problem
[Music]
this looks like a very challenging
problem
but there is a simple way to solve it
first construct ef
then notice that the region afe
is exactly congruent to the region fdc
by construction of the quarter circles
so we can move this blue area afe
over to fdc
we've simply shifted the blue area so
now we want to calculate the blue area
that remains
so recall that a b is equal to four
that means b e is equal to four since bc
was equal to eight that means ec is
equal to eight minus four which is equal
to four
and then cd is equal to a b which is
equal to four
so now the area of the blue region is
exactly the area of the square e c d f
which is equal to four times four which
equals sixteen
and that's the answer
thanks for making us one of the best
communities on youtube see you next
episode of mind your decisions where we
solve the world's problems one video at
a time
[Music]